un coeur artificiel bas depuis ce midi
dans la poitrine d'un homme greffe
réussie à salt lake city aux états unis
en espagne le nouveau gouvernement
socialiste a prêté serment ce matin une
menace toujours présente le terrorisme
basque
ouverture aujourd'hui à paris du
français des geôliers du baron empain
coup de filet anti mafia en sicile
la loi du silence ébranlée depuis la
visite du pape
madame monsieur bonsoir le coup 1
million 400 mille francs
le poids 300 g la composition plastique
et aluminium
la forme celle d'un coeur d'un coeur
humain
le miracle le coeur artificiel greffe et
ce matin dans un hôpital américain à
salt lake city bat depuis quelques
heures dans le corps d'un homme de 61
ans un nouveau bond dans la technologie
médicale vient ainsi d'être franchi son
auteur est un médecin de 36 ans martine
allain regnault voici le dentiste
originaire de seattle qui en toute
connaissance de cause a accepté
l'opération de la dernière chance
on lui a échangé cette nuit son coeur
malade contre une pompe c'est dans cette
clinique que les chirurgiens ont
implanté le premier coeur artificiel nom
provisoire qui peut rendre un cardiaque
grabataire une certaine autonomie
ce choeur le web formé de deux
ventricules d'un système moteur de
systèmes régulateurs mélange d'aluminium
et de polyuréthane il a pratiquement le
volume d'un corps humain naturel avec
sucker tout a été ajustée miniaturisés
de façon à pouvoir tenir dans la
poitrine du patient à la place de
l'ancien cat ou à l'exception de la
source d'énergie qui reste externe mais
qui a cependant pu être réduite à la
taille d'une valise torstar ici le
risque n'est pas le rejet c'est la panne
voici deux ans cette équipe avait déjà
envisagé de tenter l'expérience fut
l'autorisation lui avait été refusé l'as
vence techniques n'étaient pas jugées
suffisantes par les autorités fédérales
aujourd'hui elle est devenue comme l'a
expliqué le suivre
sitôt après l'intervention avec sa
valise d'énergie à la main le patient
pourra disposer d'une autonomie de 8
heures avant de recharger ses batteries
et voici la vente celui qui a conçu la
machine miniature il nous explique que
le patient se porte aussi bien que
possible
cinquante minutes après l'intervention
fier de ce premier succès ne compte pas
en rester là mais continue et des
recherches sur les animaux pour tenter
de réduire encore la source d'énergie
qui alimente les coeurs artificiels et
augmenter la durée le confort de cette
autonomie
l'équipe de salt lake city n'est pas la
seule on s'en doute loin de là en faut
prendre 17 heures de telles recherches
plusieurs autres états unis ont mis au
point d'autres modèles et un peu partout
dans le monde les chercheurs sont au
travail sur différents projets le
professeur pierre marion et travaillé un
temps avec cette équipe gagnante nous
explique pourquoi la france n'est pas je
crois que nous avons un moment manqué le
train on n'a pas pris le point moment où
il fallait le prendre alors actuellement
on essaye de remonter mais avec pas mal
de difficultés en particulier dans la
conjoncture actuelle économique il est
difficile évidemment de prévoir le
combler ce retard
des pays comme l'allemagne comme
l'autriche comme la tchécoslovaquie
voire même l'italie ont également fait
un effort mais nous ne l'avons pas fait
l étage si vous voulez des structures de
recherche cet effort je pense que
actuellement maintenant que l'exclusion
semble avoir compris à avoir pris la
fois dans cette recherche
je pense que des crédits sont alloués
aux chercheurs une équipe parisienne
dans la moiteur de carpentier par
exemple la paire et marseille également
le dans la boîte heures de mon pied
c'est évidemment là lyon vous pensez
qu'on pourra rattraper le retard
en tout cas je puis vous savez même si
cette tentative réussie
est ce que nous souhaitons tous et il
est évident que ça ne sera pas le
dernier modèle
c'est un peu comme une locomotive n'est
ce pas nous avons une locomotive souci
m'attendais avant le tgv et il est
évident que chacun dans chaque pays
chaque des chaque ingénieur pour
apporter une innovation c'est une autre
problème de
d'imagination de volonté créatrice est
aussi d' enthousiasme général un beau
progrès en tout cas le chiffre du jour
illustrent l'aggravation du chômage en
allemagne fédérale et cela à la veille
d'un sommet européen dominé par la crise
économique générale
un peu plus de 2 millions de chômeurs
ont été recensés en allemagne en
novembre soit 8,4 pour cent de la
population active contre 9 % en france
c'est le niveau le plus haut jamais
atteint en allemagne depuis la guerre à
copenhague demain et samedi les chefs
d'état et de gouvernement de la
communauté devront affronter est
confronté à nouveau leurs difficultés
internes
la france entend répondre aux
accusations de protectionnisme lancées
contre elles notamment par l'allemagne à
l'ordre du jour également les problèmes
de l'élargissement de la communauté au
portugal et à l'espagne
la volonté d'entrer le plus rapidement
possible dans le marché commun le gel en
revanche de l'intégration à l'otan et
l'organisation d'un référendum à ce
sujet quels sont les deux points de
politique étrangère qui ont marqué hier
au parlement espagnol
le débat d'investiture du nouveau
gouvernement socialiste felipe gonzalez
qui devient le premier président du
gouvernement socialiste depuis la guerre
civile est aussi le plus jeune de
l'histoire de l'espagne a prêté serment
ce matin devant le roi juan carlos
vous venez de le voir demain ce sera le
tour des membres de son gouvernement
outre les problèmes économiques la
menace la plus grave qui continue de
peser sur le régime espagnol reste lié
au séparatisme basque les terres
militaire semble loin de vouloir la
trêve esquissé par le nouveau chef de
gouvernement quelle que soit sa couleur
politique
l'enquète de partie c'est cost et jean
jacques edard est à peine une semaine
après les élections qui ont porté les
socialistes au pouvoir en espagne en
plein jour au coeur de madrid était
assassiné le général la gorman l'un des
militaires les plus prestigieux du pays
attentat revendiqué par eta militaire
organisation basque que la police disait
en perte de vitesse depuis un an
les funérailles rassemblèrent le ban et
l'arrière ban du franquisme
ce franquisme dont les représentants
pour eta militaire tient encore tous les
postes clés de l'état sous la façade de
la toute jeune démocratie espagnole
bilan 3 170 morts par le bras de théa
depuis 20 ans eta qui doit sa survie
entre autres à des règles de
clandestinité draconiennes nous avons pu
les rencontrer
pourquoi avez vous exécutez le général
lago romane quelques jours seulement
après l'arrivée au pouvoir les
socialistes l'exécution du général de la
division brunette et aurait eu lieu même
si le parti socialiste n'avait pas gagné
les élections
notre lutte répondent à une
planification globale c'est une lutte de
libération nationale et sociale et nous
devons utiliser toutes les possibilités
aux mains du peuple basque
aussi bien la voie institutionnelle que
celle de la mobilisation des masses ou
de la lutte armée
cette organisation de l'ombre et soutenu
ouvertement par un secteur de la
population basque qui n'hésite pas comme
ici dans ce bar de bilbao à afficher les
photos des militants morts pour la cause
il y à un mois ils ont été 15 % à voter
pour une coalition politique proche de
théa militaire et 7% de basques ont
accepté de dire à des enquêteurs de
madrid qu'ils étaient pour la lucarne et
en dehors du sentiment basque ce qui
unit ce petit peuple de sympathisants
c'est la répression c'est simple colored
affiche pour la mystique noces travaillé
que deux nuits ils n'ont pas voulu qu'on
les films de face et la plupart de ces
panneaux ont été peints aussi la nuit
ils ont peur de la face cachée de la
police celle qui torture sous couvert de
la loi antiterroriste
le moindre suspect peut ainsi être
gardés à vue dix jours dans un
commissariat livrés alors aux seuls
policiers qui comme les militaires sont
encore ceux du franquisme
pour la plupart puis il ya le côté
ostentatoire de la police qui a
multiplié ses patrouilles comme ici à
saint sébastien
où il y a pourtant un attentat tous les
quinze jours à une demi-heure de la la
france refuge pour les militants de thé
a dit madrid
là aussi la police des frontières a été
renforcée mais sa tâche est complète et
la juridiction française très
démocratique
il est difficile de condamner des
personnes qui n'ont commis aucun délit
sur le territoire français les gens de
eta le savent et tiennent à rester dans
les meilleurs termes avec le
gouvernement hôte envisageable pour vous
que vous puissiez porter la lutte sur le
territoire basque français en réalité
notre lutte et nos objectifs politiques
se situe à l'intérieur de ce qui est
l'état espagnol
concrètement dans le pays basque
espagnol c'est la raison pour laquelle
état n'a jamais agi n'agit pas et
n'agira pas hors des frontières
espagnoles à l'état espagnol eta demande
entre autres le droit à
l'autodétermination et le rattachement
de la navarre la marge de négociation
est faible en principe la question est
de savoir si le gouvernement socialiste
espagnol veut nous montrer sa bonne
volonté par une série d'améliorations
politique qui prouverait qu'il ouvre un
chemin certes difficile vers le progrès
et pour la construction de la régime
véritablement démocratique
mais malgré ces démonstrations de bonne
volonté ce que nous ne pourrions faire
c'est abdiquer de notre seul moyen de
lutte c'est à dire nos armes
ce que nous avons l'intention de faire
si le parti socialiste espagnol prend
des dispositions plus avancé que les
précédents gouvernements
c'est d'écouter voir avec attention ce
qu'il en résulte et agir en conséquence
eta militaire renvoie donc la balle dans
le camp des socialistes
ces mêmes socialistes qui après le coup
militaire du 23 février avait cédé aux
pressions de l'armée en réduisant
l'application des lois sur l'autonomie
du pays basque au liban après l'attentât
d'hier visant walid joumblatt le chef
progressiste de la communauté druze
attentat qui a fait quatre morts et 40
blessés
on criait aujourd'hui une flambée de
violence l'appel à la grève générale
lancé hier soir par plusieurs dirigeants
musulmans a été surtout suivie dans les
régions de ruse ou quelques accrochages
ont eu lieu mais à beyrouth le calme
règne l'alertent a pourtant été chaude
gérard ce bague poursuivre la
déstabilisation du liban paraître le but
recherché par des mains bien mystérieuse
qui se trouve en effet derrière cet
attentat utilisant du matériel
sophistiqué puisque c'est une voiture
piégée à explosion télécommandé qui a
failli coûter la vie à monsieur walid
joumblatt panique autour du leader druze
où les sauveteurs s'affole plus que le
blessé véritable miracle choqué et le
visage en sang
monsieur john blake n'est resté que
quelques heures à l'hôpital d'où il a
aussitôt lancé un appel au calme à ses
partisans dans la montagne druze qui est
déjà secoué depuis plusieurs semaines
par des affrontements entre forces
progressistes et miliciens chrétiens
cette déclaration avait pour but de
montrer que le dialogue se poursuivait
avec le président gemayel et empêcher un
embrasement général au liban quelques
incidents isolés ont cependant éclaté
aujourd'hui
la montagne druze fragile équilibre et
tâche difficile pour établir la paix
dans ce pays toujours occupée par des
armées étrangères
à beyrouth les partis de gauche ont
appelé à la grève générale pour
aujourd'hui la plupart des boutiques
avaient baissé leurs rideaux et les
terrasses de café est évident il faut
rappeler que le père de monsieur walid
joumblatt kamil jeu kamal joumblatt est
mort assassiné en mars 1977 en pleine
guerre civile
tandis que le ministre français de la
défense charles hernu est attendu ce
soir à beyrouth le président gemayel a
demandé l'intervention personnelle du
président reagan auprès d'israël pour
débloquer les négociations sur le
retrait des troupes israéliennes le
monde politique américain refait ses
comptes et réajuste ses pronostics
depuis que le sénateur edward kennedy a
annoncé hier qu'il renonçait à briguer
la candidature du parti démocrate pour
les prochaines élections présidentielles
américaines de 84 les spéculations vont
bon train et washington sur les
motivations réelles du dernier des
frères kennedy est aussi sur sa tactique
à long terme de washington les passants
d'edward kennedy change en fait bien peu
de choses aux perspectives
présidentielle de 82 si ce n'est de
permettre au principal intéressé
brillamment réélu sénateur il y a moins
d'un mois et cela pour six ans de régler
maintenant tranquillement un certain
nombre de problèmes
un de se retrouver plus près de ses
trois enfants c'est l'argument qu'il a
donné hier deux de mener à bien son
divorce pour ensuite le faire oublier
l'amérique a toujours mal accepté les
démêlés conjugaux de ces politiciens et
enfin de prendre le temps de réfléchir
s'il ne l'a pas déjà fait à cette
étrange coïncidence qui fait que son
mandat de sénateur va arriver à terme en
autre échéance présidentielle américaine
à laquelle ronald regan ne pourra pas
prétendre puisque la constitution ne
permet pas de solliciter un troisième
mandat et qu'après tout en 88
edward kennedy n'aura que 56 ans avec
trois enfants qui auront d'ici là
quelques peu grandi en pologne le régime
durci son offensive contre les acteurs
qui refusent obstinément depuis l'état
de siège de collaborer à la télévision
nationale l'association des acteurs
polonais vient d'être dissoute l'aï dans
le mouvement des professionnels du
spectacle qui de paris tente de soutenir
leurs camarades polonais lance un nouvel
appel à la générosité des artistes
français face à la double pression
qu'exerce temps pologne sur les artistes
le régime et l'église en france la
préparation des municipales continue
bien sûr de nourrir l'activité politique
le secrétaire général du rpr bernard
pons a présenté aujourd'hui un bilan
positif des accords intervenus au sein
de l'opposition limitant les cas
litigieux à trois grandes villes
metz nice et lyon pierre méhaignerie
président du cds s'est dit moins
optimiste le rpr va trop loin at il
déclaré prenant pour exemple le cas du
xviiie arrondissement à paris ou le rpr
alain juppé a l'intention de se
présenter malgré la présence de l'udf
ranger chinaud à paris toujours jean
marie le pen sera le candidat de son
parti le front national dans le 20e
arrondissement
côté socialiste jacques delors sera tête
de liste
a clichy le sénat qui a repoussé hier
soir le budget de la culture a examiné
aujourd'hui celui de la communication
ce qui a donné lieu à des échanges un
peu vifs sur la qualité et l'objectivité
de la télévision entre le président de
la commission des finances monsieur
bonnefous et le ministre de la
communication georges fillioud les
sénateurs on vilipende y est la taxe sur
les magnétoscopes et se sont inquiétés
de l'apparition de la publicité dans la
télévision régionale répondant à
monsieur k y avait monsieur fillon a
précisé que des négociations étaient en
cours avec la presse régionale
un sondage éclairant sur une question
qui continue de passionner les 1000
politique et l'opinion celle de
l'enseignement privé plus de deux tiers
des français sont pour le maintien du
secteur privé et cette existence avec le
secteur public selon un sondage publié
dans le magazine sélection du reader's
digest
le procès s'est ouvert cet après-midi à
la cour d'assises de paris
et l'homme que l'on guettait le plus
n'était pas au banc des accusés le baron
edouard-jean empain impossible à
affronter les photographes et les
journalistes qui en négliger presque les
deux femmes et les six hommes assis au
banc des inculpés dominique tierces et
paul lefèvre
il est un peu moins de 13 heures lorsque
le baron edouard-jean empain entouré de
ses deux avocats maîtres du peu et
prévost se présente au palais de justice
dans la grande salle d'audience de la
cour d'assises de paris le président
verser ni annonce aux journalistes que
les huit accusés refuse de se faire
filmer dans la bousculade générale le
baron empain tu remplaces les flashs
crépitent micros et caméras se braquent
sur lui son visage est tendue face à lui
les traits avocat qui défendront les
huit personnes impliquées dans son
enlèvement puis sa séquestration
une séquestration de deux mois en 1978
c'est ce long périple que va revivre le
baron empain pendant 20 jours
le temps du procès ainsi a commencé
devant la cour d'assises de paris
l'habituel face à face entre la victime
et ses ravisseurs habituel mais toujours
empreints de dramatique les uns et les
autres se jetant des coups d'oeil
furtifs qui constitue une sorte de
dialogue que personne ne connaîtra
jamais procès tout de même étrange car
aucun des accusés ne l'ait d'enlèvement
par manque de preuves mais de
séquestration et de complicité donc
théoriquement on ne parlera de
l'enlèvement que pour mieux expliquer la
séquestration
comme l'avocat général jean libouban l'a
lui-même reconnu je ne crois pas at-il
dit que tous les auteurs de ce crime
sont dans le box
l'exercice de style il consiste à dire
c'est pas moi c'est l'autre va être donc
utiliser à fond sous l'oeil d'un jury de
sept hommes et de cinq femmes dont par
parenthèse madame de boissieu la fille
aînée du général de gaulle général de
gaulle qui disait du baron empain ce
jeune homme m'agace mais il s'agissait
d'autre sauf en 1970 au moment où le
baron empain avec son groupe s'opposer
au gouvernement français au sujet de
nucléaire
un long procès dont tout le suspense
repose sur deux questions le baron at-il
tout dit de ses souvenirs
sinon le d'iraty les difficultés des
entreprises pour en revenir à
l'actualité économique pour inciter les
banques à financer davantage les petites
et moyennes entreprises
le ministre de l'économie et des
finances a mis en place aujourd'hui un
fonds de garantie
ce fonds qui disposera de 640 millions
de francs 83 couvrira les risques des
banques en cas de défaillance des
entreprises assistées deux conflits
sociaux à signaler d'abord celui de
saint baldoph près de chambéry 1
commandes
de non grévistes a fait irruption ce
matin dans une entreprise de travaux
publics occupés depuis la semaine
dernière par une cinquantaine de
grévistes
bilan 12 grévistes blessés dont un
grièvement il a été défenestré du
premier étage les syndicats cgt cfdt
protestent contre la passivité de la
gendarmerie
et puis un conflit qui se durcit celui
des usines du soulier les grévistes ont
occupé aujourd'hui une troisième usine
du groupe qui fabrique des accessoires
automobiles en haute-loire des cadres et
des ouvriers non grévistes ont manifesté
pour obtenir l'intervention des élus
locaux
un médiateur inspecteur général du
travail vient d'être nommé pour tenter
de résoudre le conflit
en italie la police et la justice semble
décidément déterminé à durcir leur
guerre contre la grande criminalité
orchestré par la mafia en sicile 64
personnes vient d'être arrêté dans un
vaste coup de filet dirigée contre deux
familles par ailleurs rival de
l'honorable société sicilienne tandis
que se poursuit à palerme le prince est
le plus important et le plus long jamais
entrepris contre certains dirigeants
locaux
il semble bien qu'en sicile l'opinion
publique aux enfin secoué la chape de
silence que la mafia faisait peser par
tous les moyens dont il dispose à tous
les échelons de la vie collective et
aussi de la vie privée des gens et il
semble bien que la récente visite du
pape jean paul ii et contribuer à délier
les langues
hervé brusini et patrick voix reviennent
de sicile dans les couloirs du palais de
justice de palerme imperméable et barbe
noire c'est giuseppe falconnet le juge
d'instruction de l'un des plus
importants procès antimafia de ces
dernières années à ses côtés en
permanence des hommes en armes qui le
suivent comme son ombre
car giuseppe falconnet qui s'apprête à
monter dans sa voiture blindée est
devenue l'une des principales cibles de
la mafia 2 ans de travail aux 110 pages
de dossier il est l'auteur de l'acte
d'inculpation de 76 mafiosi et complice
de la mafia pour trafic de drogue
les représentants de quatre familles
mafieuses sur les 50 que compte la
sicile
d'abord philippe au pire à hainaut et
francesco in cirilo interpellé à
l'aéroport kennedy à new york le 16
janvier 1980 avec 24 kilos d'héroïne
puis l'homme à la veste pied de poule
antonio adam it on a découvert 40 kg de
drogue dans l'un de ses magasins de
milan giuseppe vallée longue et montaldo
salvatore un bruce important et surtout
la petite chanteuse esmeralda dont les
disques servait à transporter la drogue
enfin emmanuel et adam ita cardiaque il
sera ramené à l'infirmerie de la prison
quelques minutes plus tard mais le grand
absent c'est rosario spatola l'ami du
banquier sindone a actuellement détenu
aux usa spatola le petit vendeur de
l'est devenu maçon et gros entrepreneurs
enfin grâce à la drogue il n'est pas là
il a préféré rester dans sa cellule de
la prison ou de chardonne car il sait
que lorsque l'on perd lorsque la police
vous prend la justice de la mafia vous
condamne à man alors pas question d'être
transféré pour venir au procès la peur
pour la connaît aussi très bien dans la
paroisse sainte giacomo de la marine
l'un des paroissiens été tués ici même
le 26 octobre dernier
histoire d'intimider le cur est bien
connu pour ses positions anti mafia
je n'ai pas peur de mourir ou d'être qui
est parti vers man et après aussi par
réflexion parce que si je dois dire
quelque chose d'héroïque jeudi que
l'important n'est pas de vivre un an
encore mais de vivre avec dignité mais
ça c'est l'héroïsme et quelquefois et il
est bon de faire un peu d'héroïsme
mais si nous ne faisons pas d'héroïsme
jeudi que
c'est plus intéressant pour moi j' le
pille le pinnipède le pire pour moi
c'est de vivre sans espérance
ce qui change vraiment sicile
aujourd'hui c'est que certains ne
respectent plus la loi du silence
l'omerta
on parle de la mafia on commence même à
s'organiser contre elle comme ce
responsable du comité anti mafia de
cassel datcha ou pour le seul mois
d'août il y a huit tués causé la mort
pour vous qu'est ce que la mafia et en
demie je la définirait comme une forme
de fascisme et de dictature elle par le
passé plusieurs générations ont lutté
contre le fascisme et la dictature
ils ont organisé une résistance
aujourd'hui nous pouvons nous devons
parler d'un engagement contre la mafia
un engagement que nous pouvons appeler
une nouvelle résistance
les nouveaux résistants qui savent que
la mafia n'a qu'une seule réponse pour
ceux qui s'opposent à l l'assassinât
fusillade en fin d'après midi dans une
rue de paris
dans le 3e arrondissement près de la rue
du temple de malfaiteurs ont agressé un
courtier en bijoux il patrouille de
police qui passait par là s'est
interposé dans les échanges de coups de
feu un passant a été grièvement blessée
au poumon
l'un des malfaiteurs et un policier ont
été blessées plus légèrement
l'autre malfaiteur a réussi à s'enfuir
dans la creuse ce ne sont pas les
truands que l'on pourchasse mais une
bête mystérieuse qui laisse des traces
sanglantes partout où il passe la bête
de noces et son nom traqué depuis trois
semaines ne tue pas que les moutons elle
impressionne aussi les esprits
l'histoire racontée par nos confrères de
faire trois limoges à la la troisième
est quoi là-bas elle descendait la
ballon mais la bête a disparu en
septembre est passé
moi je suppose que les revenus sont
logés dans les bâtiments après nos est
tout rond il ya une quinzaine de jours
la bête est réapparu en basse marche à
ozillac près de châteauponsac monsieur
la chaise l'a vu il y en a également
subi les conséquences
trois de ces brebis ont été égorgées
selon le maire de nos la fameuse bête
ressemble à une union le fermer
d'ozillac plus imprécis évoque un animal
aux poils bruns
quoi qu'il en soit elles laissent des
empreintes les gendarmes jouent la
prudence
ils parlent plus volontiers d'un gros
chien comme le furet elle passe par là
et repart par ici en tout cas son
passage à délier bien des langues
éveiller les imaginations chez les
grands comme chez les petits qu'attend
le gros chien et parents une disent que
c'est le meilleur de moi je ne sais ce
que c'est pas une vraiment une bête
sauvage moi c'est une bête qui a été qui
a été largué par quelqu'un ou que cette
échappée de quelque part
donc elle rôde comme ça autour des
matinales va pas plus loin j'ai vu le
journal d'avant-hier il y en avait une
demi page à la une
c'est un peu dommage pour un simple
incident de ce genre et ça crée une
espèce de psychose collective et même
joie mois dans la classe et enfin les
premières
la première chose on y parle en arrivant
c'est de la bête de cette lionne et je
dirais même que ça crée en eu quelques
problèmes
les résultats du quartier qui s'est
couru à vincennes aujourd'hui
vous les voyez ces résultats le case le
17 le 4 et le 12 les rapports pour 5
francs dans l'ordre plus de 51 mille
francs dans un ordre différent un peu
plus de 4300 froid et maintenant parlez
nous du temps alain je lui paie très des
étoiles ou même des comètes peut-être
oui
les comètes regardez là derrière moi si
vous regarder ce soir s'il n'y a pas
trop de nuages y en aura - si vous
n'avez pas de nuages et si vous regardez
dans la constellation du chien vous
verriez ceci au bout de mon doigt c'est
la comète de halley et oui elle revient
pour les pas vu depuis 1910 elle sera là
en mars 86 elle est actuellement si je
compte bien 1 milliard 700 millions de
kilomètres faut vraiment avoir de bons
yeux pour l'avoir c'est le télescope du
mont palomar aux états unis qui l'a
remarqué quand vous quand elle passera
en mars 86 autour du soleil
son noyau qui fait plusieurs milliards
de tonnes mais qui ne mesure que
quelques kilomètres on aura alors une
queue une immense que 210 millions de
kilomètres alors on la verra en
attendant demain qu'est ce que l'on
verra en france eh bien on verra ce
qu'il a day - nuages etc
regardez les sur la photo satellite de
cet après-midi ce sera à peu près la
même chose demain d'une toujours une
petite dépression méditerranée qui
s'éloignent progressivement mais qui
donne sur l'est du nuage avec de la
pluie ou de la neige en montagne et
partout ailleurs de l'humidité
communique comme il n'ya pas de vent les
nuages restent là bref pour demain sur
notre carte en détail
cela nous donne le matin du mauvais
temps partout et l'après-midi de la
neige à partir de 15 cents mètres sur le
jura et les alpes de la pluie en plaine
sur la méditerranée la côte d'azur et
des adversaires orages possibles en
corse mais de la bretagne à l'aquitaine
et au languedoc progressivement on verra
apparaître quelques éclaircies beaucoup
moins en bretagne que sur l'aquitaine et
le languedoc sur le reste du pays les
deux tiers nord si vous voulez du massif
central au nord au nord est et au
cotentin brume brouillard nuages bas le
matin et nuages bas et brouillards et
brume l'après midi les températures
quant à elles resteront stationnaires
avec une petite tendance à la hausse
tout de même mais cela reste froid le
minimum c'est toujours 3 degrés dans le
reste le maximum ses 15 degrés en corse
sans commentaire ce sont les mêmes
températures depuis plusieurs jours
demain vendredi 3 décembre de minutes de
soleil en moins lever du soleil 8h26
coucher 16h54 c'est la saint françois
xavier à 23 heures que vous avez rendez
vous avec jacques merlino pour notre
dernier journal demain antenne de midi
avec daniel bilalian je vous retrouverai
avec plaisir demain soir 20h bonne
soirée